So of course in the interview since I
I'm a D I wanted my wife to be a D so
that my children can be
D. I wanted a wife mainly in dinen. You
can't get a a woman in din. Where can
you get beauty and wealth and everything
but alhamdulillah Allah gave
me a life partner who was a
dai. She was the president of one of the
local organizations in Punea.
Alhamdulillah, she's very beautiful
also. I'm happy. And the first
girl married. Here starts the planning
of the
children. And after we got married, I'm
just cutting the story short. We
traveled a lot for giving lectures. I
used to give lectures, she used to give
lecture. We traveled in many countries
all over the world. After we got married
for the
next six, seven years we traveled a lot
to America, to South Africa, then to
Australia, to Gulf countries, many
countries. And while we were traveling
for
Dava, we did a little bit of tourism
also. We saw to it that we
visited the Islamic schools available at
that time. I'm talking about the mid
'90s and the late '9s. That is about 35
to 40 years
before. 40 years
before. And when we visited the
schools, we saw that in the
school their main purpose
was we want to see to
it that the girls that come to study,
they should be allowed to wear
hijab. The children that study in the
school, they should
be able to offer salah during the school
timing when and we went into the school
it's mentioned as the objective went to
Australia what is the objective an
environment in which there is no
alcohol an environment which is
drug-free and I traveled to
across to various schools and I thought
if this is the main purpose what they're
calling Islamic school that can wear
hijab, they can pray, no alcohol, no
drug. In India where I come from, this
is common. Every Muslim man is
school, a Muslim is allowed to pray. The
girl is allowed to wear hijab. Of
course, there's no alcohol. Of course,
there is no
drug. So, I called the schools as Muslim
manage school. Alhamdulillah, living in
Australia and America, having such an
environment is good. So I'm not
criticizing them that way. But this is
not what I wanted in Islamic school.
Good what they having. Alhamdulillah.
May Allah reward them. At least they're
giving this sort of atmosphere in a
non-Muslim environment. Good. But in
India it's common. India because there's
a Muslim person in law though it's a
non-Muslim country. At the time Muslims
ruled India. India is one of the few
non-Muslim countries where a person can
practice his full Sharia. Mashallah.
So it was nothing unique for me. Most of
the Muslim managed schools in India were
like that. So what is unique for them?
Okay, it may be unique. So when I say an
Islamic school, I mean education for
both the
worlds
and some of the schools we went to the
best of schools in South Africa. I'm
talking all this in the late '90s. Now
the whole scenario has changed. Now in
the last
25 years or 30 years the things have
changed. At that
time I went to the best school in South
Africa. I won't take the
name. And I spoke to the principal he
said you know what the other private
schools charge we charge half. I said
why? Otherwise Muslims don't come to our
school. So to attract the Muslim they
kept the fees half of the private
schools.
Then the principal was telling that
though we are supposed to be the best
school in the country I won't take the
name of that
school.
Once on a Saturday night I go to a fista
hotel and I'm
shocked to see the girls of my
school in the ninth standard 10th
standard 14 years old 15 years
old. They are wearing many skirts and
going in the dance club.
Imagine studying in Islamic
school 14 year old girl 15 year old girl
in the ninth in the eth standard wearing
miniskirts and going in a nuns
club when the school starts after a
couple of days on Monday the principal
calls the
parent and tells I saw your
daughter so the parent says so what's
the
problem so what is the problem if you
saw and they started
threatening that if you don't like it
we'll remove your child we'll remove our
child from the school that means the
management is at the mercy of the
parents the situation is so bad that the
parents and this was the
situation of the best Islamic schools at
That time.